So, how do the other cues work, the ones that require two eyes?
&gt;&gt; You mean, the ones that require one eye?
&gt;&gt; Yes.
&gt;&gt; So, those are called monocular cues.
&gt;&gt; Oh, monocular.
&gt;&gt; Distinguished from binocular. and actually, I'm not really certain. Why don't
we go to Susan? Susan, how are things going over there?
&gt;&gt; Great. I'm with Paul, our winner.
&gt;&gt; Could you go into more detail about how we can perceive depth even when we're
not using both eyes.
&gt;&gt; Monocular cues, sure. Well, there's a thing called interposition, which is a
fancy word for saying when one thing appears in front of the other, it's closer
to you. So, for example, viewers at home know that this hand is closer because
it appears in front of this one.
&gt;&gt; That's interesting. So, are there any other monocular clues?
&gt;&gt; Yes, linear perspective. But this one's a little more difficult to explain, so
I'm going to send it back to the studio for you guys to do an illustration.
&gt;&gt; All right. Thanks again, Susan.